le berceau de la lutte pour les droits
civiques aux États-Unis ici on célèbre
les victoires du passé pour l'égalité on
est riche des statues comme celle de
rose l'icône de la désobéissance civile
à l'arrêt du célèbre bus ou à la refusé
de céder son siège un passage blanc
près de 70 ans plus tard à une
demi-heure de la dans le comté de landes
un autre combat est mené c'est celui de
l'accès à un système d'épuration d'eau
les luttes continuent nous dit peu mardi
mais c'est une autre lutte
à Noël je devais choisir entre des
cadeaux pour mes petits-enfants dit-elle
ou garder l'argent pour pomper l'eau
80% des gens ici n'ont pas accès à un
système d'assainissement d'eau un sujet
tabou ici
chaque maison a son système artisanal
des tuyaux installés par la famille où
les eaux usées sont littéralement
déversés dans le jardin
les eaux usées peuvent remonter à la
surface du jardin dit-elle et parfois
quand il pleut beaucoup l'eau revient
dans la maison
c'est ce qui est arrivé chez Gladys
j'ai un système vieux de 100 ans
il m'en faut un autre j'ai installé un
tuyau pour que l'eau ne remonte pas à la
maison
on se bat depuis 20 ans dit-elle et rien
n'a changé mais la loi de Joe Biden sur
l'infrastructure pourrait changer les
choses 12 milliards de dollars ont été
alloués pour développer l'infrastructure
dans des comtés comme Landes
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
dit-elle on espère que le comté recevra
un peu de cet argent on va continuer à
mettre de la pression
nous avons d'ailleurs déposé une plainte
dit-elle pour droit civique
la crainte c'est que l'argent envoyé par
le fédéral à l'état ne se rendent pas
dans la communauté
quant à relier le comté de l'Inde c'est
un système d'assainissement central
c'est un problème générationnel depuis
longtemps dit le fleuve directeur du
département de l'environnement pour
l'État et puis le type de sol rend la
tâche difficile à outils et la
population n'est pas très dense et c'est
difficile de relier les maisons un
système centralisé d'épuration
est-ce qu'on peut justifier ce montant
dit-il alors qu'on peut installer des
fosse septiques individuelles pour 20
000 dollars
avec Cherry Bradley je ne fonctionnaire
retraitée à la tête du programme sodium
is not ok c'est pas correct qu'il y ait
de louisée dans son jardin dit-elle on a
un programme pour installer les fosse
septiques et ça ne coûte que 20 dollars
d'entretien par mois
qui vient de recevoir ses fosse
septiques je n'ai plus à m'inquiéter des
fuites des tuyaux dans le jardin et
c'est juste 20 dollars par mois dit-il
ne fonctionnent pas dit-elle c'est une
solution à très court terme ce que
mettre en place un système centralisé
d'assainissement dans la ville proche de
White Road dit elle cela va être
bénéfique pour tout le monde pour des
gens comme Gladys
aujourd'hui on a la maison blanche à
l'écoute ajoute-t-elle on n'a jamais été
aussi proche d'une solution sur la télé
va continuer à faire pression pour
gagner ce combat une fois pour toute ici
Radio-Canada dans le comté de landes en
Alabama